on me dit que la valeur n'attend pas le
nombre des années
on le dit en voici la preuve les 13 ans
à peine un peu amochée par ses cascades
et déjà un langage de bruce iii système
de pose pas en quoi ça veut dire quoi
360 croiser les skis sur l'avant et
attraper l'arrière du str comme lui ils
sont 150 entre 7 et 14 ans à s'affronter
partie dure interposés il y à l'eso et
il y a le freeride du ski en terrain
accidenté
pas toujours évident mais lorsqu'on y
arrive
la sensation pour les évaluer un jury à
la recherche de futurs champions et pour
leur montrer l'exemple
voici aurélien ducroz champion du monde
de ski freeride payer quelques petits
sont quand même qu'on déjà malgré
l'orage un niveau assez impressionnant
succès un sport jeune en fait on a
commencé il ya dix ans mais aussi veut
commencer les dix ans très jeune il
arrive à des très très haut niveau
une compétition bon enfant accompagnée
d'ateliers de prévention et l'appelle
toujours le lot alors on y va
mais vous me suivez un peu plus bas un
moniteur apprend aux enfants à se servir
d'un arva un émetteur récepteur pour
retrouver les personnes ensevelies dans
une avalanche plus le temps la personne
qui était ensevelie passe de tension la
neige plus la mort a des chances
d'intervenir donc il faut aller très
très vite
c'est aussi l'objectif de cette journée
sensibiliser les skieurs le plus tôt
possible afin que la montagne une reste
pour eux qu'un plaisir